we're gonna get rolling here because the
big story coming out of the draft
because they kept it secret somehow
somehow people didn't know what the
Cardinals are gonna do everybody knew
what the cartons were gonna do and then
we finally found out last Thursday night
they took collar Murray with the first
overall pick so now the question is as
the reality show continues when will
Kyler Murray actually play for the
Arizona Cardinals well there are mixed
signals coming from the Cardinals
organization Kliff Kingsbury the head
coach told Jim Rome this week we'll see
as to whether or not Murray will be the
week 1 starter we're still working
through all those things we have Brett
Hundley here who were very excited about
but we'll see where that kind of goes in
contrast Steve Conn appearing with Rich
Eisen he's the GM who drafted Colin
Murray chyme said yes quickly
when asked if Colin Murray would start
week one we didn't draft him one overall
to ride the pine I know it's a lot to
put on his back but that's why we
drafted him so look I just think Kliff
Kingsbury is is trying to extend the
drama here of course it's gonna be
column or you don't make the guy the
first overall pick if you're not gonna
start him I know the Browns tried to do
that last year it's one of the reasons
why Baker Mayfield hated you Jackson
rallying around to Rod Taylor instead of
just going with the number one overall
pick put that guy on the field or draft
someone else who you will put on the
field yeah put him on the field
especially when you draft him to fit the
offense that you hired a coach who let's
be honest Kliff Kingsbury wasn't really
lighting up you know the coaching world
he had an average big 12 team with a
very good offensive very very bad
defense he probably would have gotten a
coordinator job he had the USC
coordinator job he then becomes a head
coach in the NFL which is insane when
you actually lay it all out so you hire
this guy you draft the perfect
quarterback for his system he's starting
day one he has to start day one I get it
you want to do the quarterback can you
know competition thing it's Brett
Hundley if maybe there was a real guy
behind them okay I can buy it for a
second it's Brett Hundley calimary rolls
out of bed is QB number one in Arizona
and you know it could be the cliff
Kingsbury's instincts mesh with what
I've seen other teams do where you draft
that quarterback high but you put him at
the bottom of the depth chart and you
you force him not that he's gonna lose
this competition but you
force him to climb the ladder because
that will cause him to build some
confidence so as he leapfrogs the other
quarterbacks on your roster he feels
better and better about himself so he
has some amount of confidence when he
gets thrown to the Wolves come on Mike I
mean I'm just actually visualizing how
funny it would look to see Brett Hundley
get the first team reps over caller
Murray and then I have Kyler Murray get
in there and be electric and throw the
ball over the yard and run and scramble
and you're like what are we even doing
here why is this even this is a joke if
Brett Hundley gets more snaps in in OTAs
and minicamp and all this stuff
then Kyler Murray so Kyler Murray's the
starter if he's not the Arizona
Cardinals just fold up the franchise and
ship and ship them somewhere else
because it's not worth having a
franchise if Conrad Murray isn't the
starter game one yeah the whole idea for
taking the guy is you don't want to pass
on the player who may become the NFL's
next big thing well there's only one way
to find out if he's the next big thing
you let him go out and be the next big
thing
let him validate why you made him that
pick and if you're wrong at least you
figure it out sooner which is why I
still thought I don't want to get off
topic here I think they should have kept
Josh Rosen just for the possibility of
Kyler Murray may not be as good as they
think he's gonna be yeah and so there's
the the scenario where you could maybe
have Callie Murray not start day one you
keep Josh Rosen you see if he could
maybe play a couple games play a little
bit better and then trade them to a team
that has an injury issue that wants to
take a shot at Josh Rosen the other
thing that I hate Mike is every time
that this happens we talk about you know
the Aaron Rodgers of the Patrick mahomes
system Aaron Rodgers it was behind Brett
Favre who's Brett Favre wouldn't retire
and Patrick mahomes yeah that was
actually set up where they're like we're
gonna have him sit behind Alec Smith but
both of those guys would have been good
whether they sat or not like that wasn't
Patrick Nolan isn't good because he sat
behind Alex Smith for a year he is good
because he's good so I think finding out
that Colin Murray is good right away is
what you want to do you know it doesn't
matter if he sits if he's good he's good
and if he's bad you'll know that too
right away hey I'm still not willing to
let the Chiefs off the hook for what
happened in 2017 when they started five
and oh they hit a
spot in the middle of the season and and
and they still continue to say they did
the right thing not benching Alec Smith
I was banging the drum put my homes in
let's see what he can do
we're hearing players say how
spectacular he is in practice Travis
Kelce was on the program talking about
how great he is in practice put him on
the field
you know III look loyalty is too rare in
sports but they were overly loyal to
Alex Smith you you moved up from like 27
to 10 to get Patrick mahomes put the guy
on the field they were able to get away
with it cuz they still made it to
playoffs that year but yeah these guys
no matter how long they sit they're
still gonna be pretty damn good when
it's time to play so I agree go with
calimary from week one yeah and this
actually my opinion I used to be a guy
who says you know what maybe let them
sit because I do think there is the one
caveat here is that there's something to
be said for a guy getting absolutely
killed his first year and his eyes going
down so he's not looking down feel
anymore he's looking at the pass rush he
kind of gets warped by that but Shawn
Salisbury a couple years ago changed my
mind said look if a guy's tough enough
he's gonna get through that in the end
if he gets you know killed his first
year if he's tough enough if he has what
it takes
he will persevere through that and you
have to find that out you want to know
right away if your guy is tough enough
if he has what it takes to be an NFL
quarterback then because cuz it's gonna
it's gonna show itself one way or the
other whether it's this year next year
the year after it doesn't matter if he
does if he lacks something crucial to be
an NFL quarterback it will it will rear
its ugly head so find it out right away
so you can move on if it's not the guy
that you want going forward yeah it's
the Troy Aikman test they threw him in
yeah 1989 the Cowboys were horrible and
that laid the foundation Eggman got
through it and he ended up being a great
quarterback but you're right if you're a
great quarterback you will get through
it it's a good litmus test and and
that's why you'll find out sooner rather
than later so if the guy isn't the guy
it met your mistake and move on and
draft somebody else trade for somebody
do something to upgrade the position
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports